Yeah. Okay, guys. So the gang said that we need to do some new intros, Sean. So do you want to take it away? We need a really good solid intro. Go me. Yes, go. Hey, everybody, this is smart list. You're listening to smart list. Good
Yeah. 好的，各位。所以大家说我们需要做一些新的开场白，肖恩。所以你想来个开场吗？我们需要一个非常扎实的好开场。来吧，我来。好的，来吧。嘿，大家好，这里是 SmartLess。你正在收听 SmartLess。好
till there podcast that everybody loves. And it's it's with Jason Bateman, me, Sean Hayes, and Will Arnett. And what happens is we bring on a guest that the other two don't know about. And it's a surprise. I'm sorry, are you
直到这是每个人都喜爱的播客。由杰森·贝特曼、我肖恩·海斯和威尔·阿奈特主持。情况是这样的，我们会请来一位另外两个人并不知道的嘉宾。这是一个惊喜。抱歉，你
in a race? Because I've never heard anybody read something so quickly. All right, it's all new smart list. Let's go. Okay, now listen, I'm going to I'm going to cry here. So just okay, it's going to be tough for me to get through this. But
在赶时间吗？因为我从来没听过有人读东西这么快。好吧，全新的 SmartLess 开始了。我们走吧。好了，听着，我快要……我快要哭了。所以，好吧……我很难把这段录完。但是
if if there was a way that we could get Chumbawamba to cover $5 foot long song from subway in a duet with with the Bahaman for who do who let the dogs out if we could get them. Oh, God, are you okay? Pull it together. Well, I saw you yesterday spent
如果……如果我们能让“羊毛山”乐队（Chumbawamba）把赛百味（Subway）的“五美元英尺长三明治”之歌翻唱成二重唱，和巴哈曼人（Baha Men）的《谁放出了狗》（Who Let the Dogs Out）搭档，如果我们能请到他们的话……哦，天哪，你还好吗？振作点。好吧，我昨天看到你
the whole day with you and you didn't have a mustache. I did. No, you didn't. What's going on with you? Do you have to shave like three times a day? And I've just never known it. No, you know what it is? The first of all, my the current stash that I've
跟你整整呆了一天，你当时可没有胡子。我有。不，你没有。你这是怎么了？难道你一天得刮三次胡子，而我从来不知道？不，你知道是怎么回事吗？首先，我……我目前留的这个胡子，
got going, I like to call it the Mater D. And I want it accomplished. I look like I look like Jonathan, you know, what's his name? We played the Mater D Ferris Bueller's Day off, you know, Jimmy Valley's old comedy part is also in the pilot of
我喜欢叫它“领班”（Maître d'）。我想达到这种效果……我看起来像……我看起来像乔纳森……叫什么来着？我们在《春天不是读书天》（Ferris Bueller's Day Off）里演领班的那个，你知道的，吉米·瓦利（Jimmy Valley）的老喜剧搭档也在《发展受阻》（Arrested
rest development. Yes, and he was also in you do look just like him. That's funny. Also he had no inflates and he was great. So you've worked with him. How many times you still don't know his last name? Got it. Jonathan Schmock. Schmock.
Development）试播集里。是的，他还在……你看起来真的跟他一模一样。太好笑了。而且他没有充气腮帮，他演得真棒。所以你跟他合作过。几次了？你还是不知道他的姓氏？知道了。乔纳森·施莫克（Jonathan Schmock）。施莫克。
Yeah. Go ahead. We can wait. Listener will wait. Watch this. So Valley. Go ahead. Sean talk. Okay, so I was I was I love being told what to do. Sean Shut up. Always talking all the time. I was scrolling through the guy this week and the bucket
对。说吧。我们可以等。听众会等的。看着。所以，瓦利。说吧。肖恩，说。好吧，所以我当时……我喜欢听别人的指挥。肖恩，闭嘴。整天喋喋不休。我这周在看那个家伙，当时正在放“遗愿清单”，我知道你们都知道，我也经常谈起，但是，等等，等等，嘿，我们在录音的时候能不能别嚼东西？你知道的，你可没在休息，大块头。杰森，他们昨天和某人一起打高尔夫球，
list was on and I know you guys know and I've talked about a lot, but wait, wait, hey, can we not chew while we're recording? You know, you're not on a break, chunk. Jason, they were playing golf with somebody yesterday and
他们……不好意思，我有个老爹肚，我说，是的，现在很多地方甚至不是“麦芬顶”（腰间赘肉），而是整个都是麦芬了。其实，你们俩都知道那不是真的。我是说，我现在的身材其实练得相当不错。真的吗？你可以
they excuse me having a dad Bob and I said, Yeah, it's a lot of it's not even muffin top right now. It's just all muffin. Actually, you both know that's not true. I mean, I'm actually getting in pretty good shape. Really? You can
这么说，但我们都能看出来。你怎么不跟你的身体说说呢？好吧，各位，让我说完。对我来说身材相当不错了。对。伙计们，我今天的嘉宾获得的艾美奖和美国演员工会奖比历史上任何其他人类都要多。
say it, but we can see it. Why don't you tell your body? Yeah. All right, guys, let me finish. Pretty good shape for me. Yeah. Guys, my guest today has one more Emmys and screen actors Guild than any other human being in
埃里克·麦柯马克。2018年，她获得了肯尼迪中心荣誉奖之马克·吐温美国幽默奖。而且我们当年还竞争过《宋飞传》（Seinfeld）里的同一个角色。女士们先生们，茱莉亚·路易斯-德利法斯（Julia Louis-Dreyfus）。哦，天哪。哦，
history. Eric McCormick. In 2018, she received the Kennedy Center's honor of the Mark Twain Prize for American humor. And also we were up for the same part on Seinfeld. Ladies and gentlemen, Julia Louis-Dreyfus. Oh my God. Oh
天哪。嗨，伙计们。独一无二的，带着牙齿的那位。她牙齿真好看。哇。超级巨星们这些应和真是太奉承了。对啊，我知道，难道你不觉得受宠若惊吗？我同意来。对。你们付给她多少钱？就
my. Hi guys. The one, the only with the teeth. She's got nice teeth. Wow. So flattering these yeses from these super stars. Yeah, I know, aren't you flattered? I agree to come on. Yeah. How much are you paying her? Just
按收益分成的一部分。其实还挺多的，这挺让人愉快的。我的意思是，这绝对是一场谈判，但结果对我很利。所以听我说。你是有史以来最搞笑的人之一，如果不是最搞笑的话。对，
like a portion of the proceeds. Quite a lot, actually, but which is delightful. I mean, it was a negotiation for sure, but it worked out in my favor. So listen to me. You're one of the funniest people alive, if not the funniest person alive. Yes,
那是真的。对。获得的艾美奖和美国演员工会奖比任何其他人都要多。哇。真的吗？太疯狂了。得了吧，茱莉亚。你才不在乎呢。这消息对你来说很新鲜，对吧？这对我来说是新鲜事。胡扯。是真的吗？不，这还未可知。
that's true. Yeah. One more Emmys and screen actors Guild awards than any other person. Wow. Is that true? Crazy. Come on, Julia. You don't give a shit. This is news to you, isn't it? It's news to me. Bullshit. Is that true? No, it's unknown.
肯定是。不，这不是新鲜事。我是说，我不确定关于工会奖的事是不是真的，而且这一切都非常可爱之类。但归根结底，我觉得你并不是为了拿奖才去演戏的。无意冒犯奖项，而且如果奖项真的砸向我，我会照单全收。
It's got to be. No, it's not news. I mean, I'm not sure that's true about the SAG awards and and it's all very lovely and stuff. But at the end of the day, I don't think you're really in it to win awards. No offense to awards and I'll take more if
当然。你知道我在说什么吗？这就是为什么我一直拒绝获奖。我从来没赢过。他正是为了你刚才指出的那个原因而拒绝的。他们让他知道他获奖了。他说，不，谢谢。谢谢。然后他们把奖颁给
they come my way. Sure. You know what I'm saying? It's why I've always rejected winning. I've never won. He turns away for that very reason that you're pointing out. They'd let him know that he won. He says, no, thank you. Thank you. And then they give it
别人了。奥斯卡、艾美奖、托尼奖，什么都一样。但尽管如此，不管这有多谦虚，而且它必须……其实一点也不谦虚。嗯，不过确实……感觉有一种认可，而且这种感觉很好，
to somebody else. Oscars, Emmys, Tonys, everything. But it is however, as modest as that is and it's got to It's not modest, really. Well, but it is like it feels there is that validation and it's great
你知道的，你这么长时间以来一直如此出色地完成如此棒的工作。对，你没有停止工作。你不累吗？我是有点累，但我喜欢工作。我知道为什么。我也是。我也喜欢工作，因为这样我就不用面对自己了。
to, you know, you do such great work so consistently for a long time. Yeah, you don't stop working. Aren't you exhausted? I am a little tired, but I like working. I know why. I do. I love working too because so I don't have to be with myself.
但是，但是……想想茱莉亚被邀请去做的事情，或者她追求的东西，或者这一切是怎么运作的。我的意思是，这就像是有史以来最棒的一些东西，你一定很喜欢。我是说，你拿起那些……
But what but the stuff but think about the things that Julia has been invited to do or pursued or however it all works. I mean, it's like some of the best stuff ever and you must love it. I mean, you pick up those.
我还记得我有过这种感觉，威尔，当我们拍《发展受阻》的时候，剧本会送来。那是还在用纸质剧本的年代，我会在早上五点左右开门，那天正好要拍摄。这是另一个播客，我要去参加戒瘾播客。我当时会
I remember having these feelings, Will what we were doing arrested like the script would come. This is back when it was all paper I'd open up the door at like five in the morning when we get our scripts day of shooting. It's a different podcast and I would remit the venture with recovery podcast. I would
像个粉丝一样兴高采烈地读着。我会超级兴奋，因为我们能参与这些素材。对，我们甚至什么都不用做，只要把台词说出来就行了，因为它本来就已经非常搞笑了。我的意思是，对……我的意思是，你能想起来读过糟糕的剧本吗？在你三十年的职业生涯里
read it gleefully like a fan. I'd be so excited that this material that we get to do it. Yeah, we need not do anything but just talk it because it's already so funny. I mean, for I mean, can you remember reading a bad script? It's must it's got to be 30 years
肯定遇到过吧。哦，我读过不少烂剧本，我想我也拍过不少烂片。你拿了杰森的试播集。你拿了我的独幕剧。我拿了独幕剧，我拿了故事片，我还拿了一些别的东西。我们会排练的。我们会把它改得更好。这只是初稿。我不
in your career. Oh, I've read my share of bad scripts and I think I've done my share of bad. You got Jason's pilot. You got my one act. I got the one act and I got the feature and I've gotten a few things. We'll workshop it. We'll make it better. It's just first draft. I'm not
确定。我不确定。但是，你知道，先把这事放一放。我们可以说，剧本的质量……当你遇到剧本中极高的质量时，那是令人振奋的。没有……绝对没有……然后突然之间，你不
sure. I'm not sure. But, you know, put a pin in it. Let's say that the quality of the scripts when you come across great quality in a script, it's exalting. There's no, there's no way and then all of a sudden, don't you
觉得你的创造力和灵感开始疯狂涌现，然后你开始想一些可以叠加的东西之类的吗？我想问你一个关于《宋飞传》的问题，我一直很想知道。问题来了。好吧。我可能答不上来。我没有记忆力。
find that it's like your creative energy and juices start going nuts and you start thinking of things to layer on and stuff like that. I want to ask you a question about Seinfeld that I've always wanted to know. Here it comes. All right. I won't be able to answer. I have no memory.
我知道。说吧。好吧，这更多的是关于你的经历和你的感受。当然，有很多故事，杰瑞也谈了很多关于第一季只拍了六集的事，我想最初是四集，
I know. Go ahead. Well, this is more about your experience and your feeling. Of course, there are a lot of stories out there and Jerry's talked a lot about that for a season making six episodes, I think initially in four episodes
而且甚至不是全国广播公司（NBC）的喜剧，不管是哪个部门，是另一个部门为之付的款。深夜节目。没错。哦，也是那个谁，对吧？对，是里克·勒德温（Rick Ludwin），上帝保佑。里克·勒德温。多好的人啊。你对这段经历的
and it wasn't even NBC comedy or whomever it was, a different division who paid for those. Late night programming. Exactly. Oh, it was what's his name too, wasn't it? Yeah, it was Rick Ludwin, god bless. Rick Ludwin. What a sweet man. Your memory is awful about this
记忆太糟糕了。我知道。所以，扯远了。但后来这部剧火了，现在，当然，它已经成为我们文化结构中如此重要的一部分，如果你愿意这么说的话，这是一个既恶心又真实的词。不仅仅是因为它是一部受欢迎的
experience. I know. So, but I digress. But then the show becomes and it's now, of course, such a part of that really about our cultural fabric, if you will, a term that's gross but also true. Not just that it was a popular
剧，而是因为它变成了一种这种现象。你对它跨界的那一刻有什么回忆？你有没有过那样的一个时刻，让你觉得，哦，天哪，这比我们拍一部剧要大得多。这已经变成了别的东西。你知道，我可以这么说
show, but that because it became this sort of phenomenon. What was your recollection of that moment when it sort of crossed over? Did you have a moment like that where you went like, oh my god, this is bigger than us doing a show. This has become something else. You know, I can sort of say
其实那种事从来没有真正发生过。因为我们……我想，首先，我认为这部剧的受欢迎程度在我们停播后呈指数级增长。而且
that that didn't quite ever happen. Because we were I think, first of all, I think the show's popularity grew exponentially once we were off the air. And
一旦我们结束了第九季，我认为人们对这部剧的怀旧之情就开始增长。简直太庞大了。而且，你知道的，你们也知道拍一部剧是什么感觉。我的意思是，你进去，围读剧本，排练，彩排，你知道的，你深陷其中，你在努力工作。顺便说一句，在这段期间，在那九年里，我在期间生了两个孩子。所以带着
as soon as we wrapped that ninth season, I think the nostalgia for the show just sort of grew. It was just mammoth. And also, you know, you guys know what it's like doing a
年幼的孩子，还要应付这些工作时间——那可是很长的工作时间——这让我把注意力集中在了别的地方。我确实……我确实记得我们在拍大结局的时候，
show. I mean, you go in, you table read, you rehearse, you have run-throughs, you know, you're in the weeds on it, you're working on it. And also, by the way, during this time, those nine years, I had two kids during this time. So having
我们是在 CBS 雷德福（Radford）片场拍的。一个有趣的小花絮。你们拍大结局的那个片场和《威尔和格蕾丝》（Will & Grace）是同一个。哼。棒。棒。除了……难道你们当时没有……你们拍《威尔和格蕾丝》的时候跟我们是同一时期吗，
young children and sort of juggling these hours, which were long hours, and was it sort of kept my focus elsewhere. I will, I do remember when we were shooting the finale
还是没有？我想大概只有最后一年吧，也许是最后一年左右。我不知道。所以我们当时在拍大结局，我记得他们不得不在雷德福周围设置路障，因为外面有很多人拿着
and we shot the show over at CBS Radford. A little interesting tidbit. You shot your finale on the same stage as Will and Grace. Huh. Bam. Bam. Except weren't you guys, were you shooting Will and Grace at all at the same time we were
长焦镜头，试图看那些来客串大结局的演员。哇。而且我记得当时我很震惊。说真的，谁在乎啊？这只是一群……你知道的，一群演员工会的朋友过来，
or no? I think just the last year maybe, maybe the last year or something. I don't know. And so we were shooting the finale and I remember that they had to put barricades up all along Radford because there were people out there
我们拍完这个，然后我们要办个派对，这就结束了。我的意思是，那是……那是一个让我觉得，哇，人们对它的投入如此之深，这真的很神奇的时刻。茱莉亚，我……我迷恋那种……你知道的，人们的经历，
with telephoto lenses trying to see the actors that were coming in to be guest stars on the finale. Wow. And I remember being so shocked. Like, seriously, who gives a shit? It's just, you know, a bunch of members of SAG are coming through
我知道你可能已经厌倦了谈论它，但是……比如你小时候就很搞笑吗？你有没有过这样的梦想，比如你看着卡罗尔·伯内特（Carol Burnett），然后想，哦，天哪，我想成为她那样的人……比如是什么让你想要做这一切？或者你家里一直有人从事戏剧行业吗？
that are friends. We're doing this and then we're going to have a party and that's the end of it. I mean, it was, that was a moment in which I thought, wow, that's really amazing that people are that invested in it. Julia, I'm like, I'm obsessed with people's
没有，因为你爸爸是个疯狂的亿万富翁农业大亨。好吧，首先，他不是亿万富翁。我总是不得不这么说，我知道这听起来很疯狂，但外界就是这么传的，而且这不是真的，要真是那样就好了。不过我……我不知道。我总是喜欢……是的，
like, you know, beginnings and I know you're probably sick of talking about it, but like, were you funny as a tiny kid and were you like, did you ever like dream, like you watched Carol Burnett and be like, oh my god, I want to be like her and like, like what made you want to like do all of it? Or were you always
我……我想我是搞笑的。我总是试图逗我妈妈笑之类的。而且我……我曾经迷恋过……在我很小的时候有一段时间，我会看……
did somebody in your family in theater? No, because your dad's like this crazy billionaire agriculture guy. Well, first of all, he's not a billionaire. I always have to say that which I know sounds crazy, but it's out there and it's not true if only it were, but I I don't know. I always like to, yes,
我经常看《音乐之声》（The Sound of Music）、《欢乐满人间》（Mary Poppins）和《妙女郎》（Funny Girl），那是在录像带出现之前的年代，所以你每个周末都会去看电影，我会一遍又一遍地看这些电影。我
I was, I think, I think that I was funny. I was always trying to make my mom laugh or and shit like that. And I was, and I was in love with there was a period of my life when I was really young where I would watch
记得很小的时候心想，我只需要……我非得见到芭芭拉（芭芭拉·史翠珊）不可，我知道如果我们见了面，我们会成为最好的朋友。我心里就是这么确定的，
I watched The Sound of Music and Mary Poppins and Funny Girl all the time and this was back before they videotaped so you would go to the movies every weekend and I would watch these movies over and over again. And I
几十年后我终于有机会见到她了，我们在白宫记者协会晚宴上，我看到她在那里，我得说点什么，于是我就走过去
remember thinking when I was really little that I just needed I just had to meet Barbara and I knew that if we met each other that we would become such best friends. I just knew it in my heart and
对她说：“嘿，芭芭拉，我是茱莉亚·路易斯-德利法斯，我只是想告诉你，能见到你真是太荣幸了。”她却说了类似这样的话：“不，我已经告诉他们我想要什么了……”
I had the opportunity to meet her decades later we were at the White House Correspondents' Dinner and I saw she was over there and I got to say something and so and I went over
哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈，太搞笑了。不可能，我发誓。你是像蛇一样溜走了，还是死缠烂打？
to her and I said, hey Barbara I'm Julie Lou Drivers and I just wanted to tell you just that such a treat to meet you and she said something like no I already told them what I wanted
哦，我直接……好吧，没有什么比羞辱更……简直无法夸大这些时刻是如何伴随着你，而且美好的事情其实并没有那种
hahahaha hahahaha hahahaha that's hilarious. No way I swear Did you slither away or did you or did you dig in?
粘性，但羞辱感实在是太惊人了。对于喜剧来说这也是一种奇妙的体验呢。所以当我16岁的时候——这个故事没有任何名人互动，但我知道……
Oh I just went right okay there's nothing like humiliation there's just cannot be overstated how those moments stay with you and they just the good things don't really have the same
我知道。所以我大约16岁时在多伦多，我在等一个朋友，我靠在一棵树上，正好在多伦多所有大学生聚集的那个区域，这三个大学生走过来，两个男生和一个女生，
stickiness but humiliation is unbelievable. It's kind of fantastic too for comedy so when I was 16 this story is void of any celebrity interaction but I know
离我最近的那个男生——我当时16岁，我在抽烟，姿势很拙劣，装出一副很酷的样子在等朋友——他们从我身边走过，离我最近的那个男生甚至没有中断
I know so I was about 16 and I was in Toronto when I was waiting for a friend and I was leaning against a tree and I was right in this part of Toronto where all these college students are and these three college students come walking along two guys and a girl
他正在和朋友进行的对话，转过头对我说：“怎么了，酷哥？”然后继续往前走。我的整段脊椎骨都从我体内飞出去了，我是如此地感到羞辱。他竟然看到我在那个时刻那么努力地装酷，我是如此地羞辱。我太喜欢了。
and the guy closest to me and I'm 16 I'm like smoking right poorly trying to look cool waiting for a friend and they walk by me and the guy closest to me without breaking stride just turns out of the conversation
这家伙完全不知道，他第二天甚至不会记得他说过这话，但它留在我身上了，你知道的。我觉得你听起来棒极了，非常酷，太尴尬了。我记得——我知道这是一个全是男人的座谈会，但我才不在乎呢——
he's having with his friends and he goes what's up cool guy and then keeps walking and my entire my spine came out of my body and I was so humiliated he had seen me trying so hard in that moment and I was so humiliated I love it
我记得我第一次来月经的时候我很小，我也是，我想我大概11或12岁，当时有一个舞会，我读的是一所全女子学校，所以要和一个男校举办一场舞会，
and this guy has no idea he wouldn't remember the next day that he said and he stayed with me you know I think you sound amazing very cool so embarrassing I remember and I know this is a panel of men but I don't give a shit
这是……对不起，伙计们，我不得不说。我本想说有一群狗跟着你去舞会。所以……我当时垫着卫生巾，
I remember when I got my period when I was really young me too and I think I was like 11 or 12 and there was a dance and I went to an all girls school so there was some dance with the boys school
所以你知道那玩意儿很厚。我记得走进学校时，我看到了我的朋友们，他们知道我刚来月经，这可是个大事。我于是做了一个相扑深蹲的动作，开始朝他们走去想搞笑一下，
and this was and I'm sorry guys I have to I was going to say there was a herd of dogs following you to the dance and so and I was wearing a sanitary sanitary pad
我只记得所有的女孩都在说：“哦……天哪，这太酷了。”你撑完整场舞会了吗？你当时都做了什么？好吧，我可以告诉你一件事，那场舞会上没有一个男生向你邀舞，但你待到了最后。
and so you know that thing is bulky and I remember walking into the school and I seen my friends and they knew I just got my period it was such a big deal and I sort of did this sumo squat and started walking over to them to be funny and
你当时是说你的女朋友们觉得这很酷，还是觉得很恶心，还是她们笑了，或者没笑？不，她们没笑，她们觉得一点也不好笑，她们觉得我是……谢天谢地你做了。是的，虽然你知道，当我没有得到任何反应时，我并不觉得好笑，
I just remember all the girls going oh like that is so cool and did you got all the way through the dance like what did you do well I can tell you one thing there's not one boy who has made a dance at that dance but you stayed the whole time
你知道的，我摆出了那种姿势，走来走去还蹲着。但这并没有阻止你一生中都表现得大胆和勇敢，敢于让自己出丑，这简直就是幽默的关键。
did you say that your girlfriend said that it was cool or it was gross or did they laugh or not no they didn't laugh they didn't think it was funny they thought I was thank god you did yeah although you know I didn't think it was funny when I got no reaction
愿意让自己难堪，或者（比喻意义上地）脱下裤子。是的，我的意思是，你真的必须要……确实如此，你必须承担那种风险，有时你必须承受这种风险带来的失败，这无疑会
you know and I made this really you know I was like and walking around squatting but didn't stop you from being bold and courageous your whole life by making a fool out of yourself which is like the key to humor
一次又一次地发生，但你必须这么做。说回那些搞笑的羞辱故事，它们是我的最爱。还有医疗故事我也很喜欢，因为我有太多了。两年前我差点死掉，当时我的小肠在
being willing to embarrass yourself or you know pull your pants down figuratively yeah I mean you really do have to it's true you do have to take that risk and sometimes you have to live with the failure of that risk which will
半夜突然破裂了，我去了锡安山医学中心（Cedars），自己开的车。斯科蒂（我丈夫）讨厌我这么说，因为我当时不想吵醒他，所以我开车到了锡安山的代客泊车处，把钥匙扔给泊车小哥，他问：“什么？”我说：“随便停在哪都行。”然后我走进去，捂着肚子
undoubtedly happen time and time again but you must do that going back to the funny humiliating stories they're my favorite those in medical stories I love because I have tons I almost died two years ago when my small intestine burst open
弯着腰，那家伙问：“怎么了？”我说：“我不知道他妈的怎么了，我在这儿，我在问你呢。”我想问你……是的，到底有什么问题？我不知道，我的肚子，我觉得我要死了。他们做了所有的检查，然后说：“哦，你马上需要紧急手术。”我的小肠破裂了，
in the middle of the night and I went to Cedars drove myself Scotty my husband hates when I say that because I didn't want to wake him and so I drove up to the valet at Cedars sign a hospital through my keys at the valet and he's like what I go just to park it anywhere and I go in and I'm bent over
就像在污染我的整个身体。后来我去奥兹医生（Dr. Oz）的节目上谈论这件事，他说：“在我整个职业生涯中，我从来、从来没见过这种情况。”首先，让我说一件事，是的，奥兹医生不应该是你的医生，没错。
with my stomach and the guy goes what's wrong I go I don't know fucking no I'm here I'm asking you I want to ask you yeah and what's the problem I don't know my stomach I feel like I'm dying and they did all these tests and like oh you need emergency surgery right away and my small part of my intestine burst open
哦，操。你也不应该让他进你体内到处看。我不知道，他当时就在他的节目上……他可不是那块料。有人说——不是我，但有人说他是江湖郎中，肖恩。是的。不管怎样，所以我喜欢医疗故事，但说回羞辱故事，我想我大概……
and was like polluting my whole body and then I went on doctor Oz to talk about it and he said in my entire history I've never ever seen this well first of all let me say one thing yeah dr. Oz should not be your doctor correct
这跟阑尾炎有什么区别，顺便问一下？是的，是的，怎么会……但阑尾炎是你身体的不同部位，我不明白你的小肠是怎么破裂的，这是否意味着你需要一个袋子……展示你的造口袋。等等，肖恩，你想看我的伤疤吗？你想看我的伤疤吗？是的。你当时在手术台上，
oh shit nor should you let him inside your body to look around I don't know he was just on his showed he's not the guy there are those who say not me but there are those who say that he's a quack Sean yeah what anyway so I love medical stories but back to humiliating stories which I think I probably
在手术台上的时候，你还在说：“把我安排到奥兹医生节目上。”所以等等，你能看到……你能看到那里有个小洞吗？我什么也看不见。剖腹产？真的吗？哦，等等，我做过剖腹产。我有两只狗，但我并不认为
just how is that different than an appendix by the way yeah yeah how is that but appendix is a different part of your body and I don't understand how your small intestine burst and does this mean you need a class to be back show show your bag but shut so Sean you want to see my scar you want to see my scar yeah are you on the operating table
我是这么生下它们的。斯科蒂，我看起来就像其中一只。他总是说：“我们再生一个吧。”我说：“门都没有。”但瞧瞧我，我这不在这儿呢。哦，有三个孩子让隔离期过得更快了，
and as you're on the table you go book me on dr. Oz so wait you can see like a you can see like a little hole there I can't see anything section really oh wait a minute I had a C section I have two dogs but I didn't think
尤其是通过剖腹产。所以医院里……没有人知道是什么导致我的小肠破裂的。没有人知道，这就是重点。直到今天他们都不知道。他们不知道。没有答案。你不知道该如何预防它再次发生。那个救了我的命的了不起的外科医生，
that's how I got them Scotty I look just like one he always says let's try I'm like it's not gonna happen and well and behold here I am oh it makes quarantine go by faster having three kids so listen especially through C
在我做完手术、正在恢复的时候来到病房，护士也在那儿，他说：“好吧，我们要让你出院了，”这是在四五天之后，“我们明天让你出院，确保不要喝酒。”外科医生在他身后说：“别担心，你完全可以喝。”
section so the hospital no nobody knows what caused my small intestine to burst open nobody knows that's the thing to this day they don't know they don't know there's no answer you don't know how to prevent it from possible and the surgeon who's incredible saved my life he's
我说：“真的吗？”他说：“对，而且你大概不应该吃像薯片那样扎嘴的东西。”外科医生却说：“去吧，你可以吃薯片。”这还是你在墨西哥做完眼部手术之后的事吗？是的。肖恩，
in the hospital room after I'm done you know after I'm recovering and the nurses in there and you know he's like okay we're gonna release you you know this is after like four or five days we're gonna release you tomorrow make sure you don't drink alcohol and the surgeon standing behind him going don't worry about it you can totally drink
菲尔博士（Dr. Phil）还是你的治疗师吗？是的，他其实现在就在这儿。我们得赶紧结束这个……不，我……所以，我喜欢医疗故事，如果你有什么故事就插话吧，除了你那可怕的乳腺癌——我很高兴你现在恢复得很好——但我也
I'm like really and he's like yeah and you probably shouldn't eat like sharp things like potato chips and the surgeon's like go ahead you can eat potato chips was this still while you were down in Mexico with the after the eye surgery you yes and Sean
喜欢羞辱故事，比如剧院故事。我有一千个这样的故事，比如在剧院里搞砸了的事情，或者去试镜搞砸了。你有这方面的故事吗？因为我就是靠这个活着的。是的，我有。你有什么糟糕的播客故事吗？我有一个糟糕的……
is Dr. Phil still your therapist yeah he's actually here now we have to wrap this up soon so no I so I love medical stories if you have one chime in other than your horrible breast cancer and I'm so glad you're doing well but I also
播客……没有，我没有。我有太多这样的故事了，我都不知道从何说起。好吧，首先，我要从这个故事开始：我生我的第一个孩子时，我体重
like humiliating stories like like theater stories I have a thousand of them like things that gone wrong wrong in a theater or auditions that have gone wrong do you have any of those because I live for them yeah I do you have any terrible podcast stories I have a terrible
160磅，我完全……我在锡安山，我一丝不挂，我身上缠着那个……对，我肚子上缠着那个东西，你知道的，
pod no I don't I am so many of these stories I don't even know where to start okay so first of all I'm gonna start I'll tell you this story so I'm giving birth to my first child I weigh
在监测所有数据。你没必要脱得那么光吧？不，这很有必要。为了生孩子，你得……我去洗手间了，你知道的……我简直不敢相信，我快笑死了。
160 pounds I am completely I'm at Cedars I'm completely naked I've got the thing around my yeah I got the thing around my stomach you know that it's
听着，我刚才还告诉你我差点因为肚子死掉呢，对吧？所以我去了洗手间，因为我在那儿待了很久——这一胎我产程很长很长——突然之间，我的……有见红，而且我的
monitoring everything it's unnecessary for you to be so naked no it's not no it's not to have the baby you have and I go I'm in the bathroom you know I cannot believe I'm dying laughing
羊水刚好破了。所以我……我有点……我趴在马桶上，再次像刚才那样蹲着——这可以说是我的标志性动作——我像这样……你知道的，像那样蹲着，太棒了。然后这个护士
look and I just told you I almost died because of my stomach yep so I go into the bathroom and I and because I've been there for a while I was a long long labor with this one and all of a sudden my there's bloody show and there's my
走进来，看着我说：“伊莱恩？”没门！哦，天哪，哦，天哪！这糟糕不糟糕？这简直跟我的第一次也是唯一一次
water is just broken and so I've so I'm sort of I'm sort of over the toilet once again squatting like I was earlier this is kind of my signature and I'm like this you know sort of squatting like that great and this nurse
结肠镜检查有得一拼。我走进办公室门，这个甜美的女人说：“贾斯汀的弟弟？”没门！我礼貌地点了点头，她说：“去吧，带他下去，上那张桌子去，我一会儿就来。”
comes in and she looks at me and she goes it lain no way oh my god oh my god is that awful or what it's right up there with my first and only
所以，你知道的……你真的做完结肠镜检查了吗？我当然做了。但我没有通过水族馆的窗户往里看，或者有什么东西出来……就像你听说的那样，比如有一块小型自行车车牌、
Kalanik where I walked in the office door and this sweet woman says justine's brother no way I kind of nodded politely and she said go ahead take him down and get up there on that table and I'll be in in a minute
薯片、高尔夫T恤、N-W-O-L-F（拼写出“狼”），还有很多尖锐的食物和酒精。是的，我想听听关于剧院或者别的什么的故事。好，很久很久以前，我去为
so you know did you go through with the Kalanik? I sure did but I didn't look through the the aquarium window anything come out like you've heard like there was a small bike license plate
《昨夜情深》（About Last Night）试镜。你还记得那部电影吗？记得，黛米·摩尔，罗伯·劳。对，对，没错。我是为黛米·摩尔那个角色试镜，但还有另一个角色，
potato chips golf, T, N, W, O, L, F a lot of pointy foods and alcohol yeah I want to know like a theater or something yeah so long long time ago I auditioned for
由伊丽莎白·帕金斯（Elizabeth Perkins）扮演，哦，对。不管怎样，我去了试镜，导演是米奇·赫斯科维茨（Mitch Herskovitz）和另一个马歇尔·赫斯科维茨（Marshall Herskovitz）……哦，对，对，爱德华·兹威克（Ed Zwick），谢谢。向所有人道歉。
about last night do you remember that movie? yeah demi more Rob Lowe yeah yeah exactly and for the part that demi more part but the other part that played
所以我走进试镜现场，当我到那儿时，黛米·摩尔正要离开。她转了个圈，咯咯地笑了，大家都笑了，她也笑了，
by Elizabeth Perkins I believe oh yeah anyway and so I had this audition and with the directors Mitch Herskovitz and the other Marshall Herskovitz and oh yeah sorry
然后她走了出去。她美得惊人，而且显然把这次试镜拿下了。所以我走进去试读，我是如此……我太想要这份工作了。通常当我真的很想要一份工作时，我反而拿不到。
Edzwick thank you apologies to all and so I go into the audition and as I get there demi more is leaving and she does a little twirl and a giggle and everybody laughs and she laughs
百分之千。对，从来拿不到。所以我试读了，我读得一点也不好，因为我太想要这份工作了。我刚看她完美拿下，我把我所有刚拿到的东西都搞砸了。我回家后，知道自己表现得很糟，我
and then she exits and she's stunningly beautiful and she has obviously nailed this audition so I go in and I read and I am so I want this job so badly usually when I really want a job I don't get it
非常沮丧，我想：“你知道吗？我要给他们写封信，我要说：‘亲爱的爱德和马歇尔，马歇尔，我知道……我希望你们一切都好，谢谢你们给我机会为你们试读。我真的
a thousand percent yeah never and so I read and I do not read well because I want the job too much I saw her nail it I was thrown everything I just got and I went home and I knew I'd done really badly and I
觉得我在试镜时没有发挥出最好水平，我真的很感激能有再次进来的机会，这样我才能真正向你们展示我能做到什么。’”这简直是一场车祸现场！我拿着这封信回到酒店，
was so upset and I thought you know what I'm going to write them a letter and I'm going to say dear Ed and Marshall Marshall you know I'm so I hope you're well thank you for the opportunity letting me read for you I really
交给礼宾部让他们转交，然后我离开了。结果第二天，我又得到了另一次试镜机会。他们不是很nice吗？哇！还是那个角色？不同的角色？不，还是同一个角色，那个尖酸刻薄的朋友——我永远只能演这种。
feel as if I did it wasn't my best in the audition and I really appreciate the opportunity to come in again and so I can really show you what I can do this is a train wreck and I take this letter and I go back to this hotel
所以我进去了。到了这个时候，我会紧张两倍。我会吓得半死。没错，确实如此。谢谢你，杰森。我走了进去，
and I give it to the concierge person to put into their thing I leave and lo and behold next day I get another audition isn't that nice of them wow for the same part different part no same part the snarky friend that's all I ever get
我读得比第一天还要糟。就好像我……你知道，就像你拿着稿子却忍不住一直盯着看，我甚至不敢抬头，这样我就能有眼神接触，让他们看到我的脸，
and so I go in at this point I'd be twice as nervous I'd be petrified now that's right and that's what I was Jason so thank you for that and I walked in and I
所以我只能一直盯着稿子。你应该抬起头来，变成斗鸡眼，然后你应该把悲伤卡片递给他们，然后告辞：“哦，你这个可怜的人。”太搞笑了！这太残酷了，对吧？这是最糟糕的。
read worse than I read the first day it was as if I couldn't you know like you're holding the pages and you can't stop looking and I'm afraid to even bring my head up so that I have eye contact so they can even see my face
太难了。回到你生孩子、那个女人说“伊莱恩”的话题……我有一次从《威尔和格蕾丝》的拍摄现场开车回家，路上看到一个男人躺在马路中间，
so I just keep it down on the page you should have brought your eyes up crossed and then you should have handed them your sad card just excuse yourself oh you poor thing that's so funny it's brutal isn't it it's the worst
当我靠近时，我前面的车直接绕过他继续开走了。我当时想：“哦，天哪，有个人在那儿。”所以我把车靠边停下。就在我下车之前，我在想：“这会不会是什么……你知道的，那种骗局？
it's so hard back to your having giving birth and the woman says Elaine I was driving home from a taping of Will and Grace and there is a man in the middle of the street lying there
让我下车，然后他从什么地方突然跳出来袭击我，把我的车偷走之类的？”但我心想：“不，这值得。”所以我下车了。那家伙刚刚中枪了，我当时想：“哦，天哪。”我脱下衬衫，把它按在伤口上，
and as I was approaching the car in front of me just drove around him and kept driving and I was like oh my god there's this man so I pull over and just before I get out I'm thinking is this one of those you know scams
手里拿着电话。到那时，其他一些人也出来了。我一直等到救护车赶到，我对他说：“你会没事的，你会没事的。”救护车上下来的第一个人说：“贾克（Jack）？”我说……
where I'm supposed to get out and then he comes out of somewhere and jumps me and takes my car or whatever but I'm like no it's worth it so I got out and the guy had just been shot and I was like oh my god I took my shirt off and I put it on the wound
我当时光着膀子，我说：“有一个人在中间快要死了……”顺便说一句，结局很棒，他活下来了，一切都很好，他也很棒。
with my phone and then by then some other people had come out and I wait till the ambulance gets there and I'm like you're gonna be fine you're gonna be fine and the first guy gets out of the ambulance and goes just Jack and I'm like
但这难道不疯狂吗？太疯狂了。你的小肠又破裂了吗？那是第一次。这是在那之前，我的大肠先出了问题，算是一个前兆。但等等，我想知道……
and I'm like well there's a man and I'm shirtless I'm like there's a man dying in the middle by the way the end of the story is great he lived everything's fine and he was great
你有没有达到这样一个地步：因为你工作真的很多，而且你做过那么多惊人的事情，你在其中每一件里都表现得才华横溢——你有没有达到这样一个地步，让你觉得：“天哪，这演艺圈的事情太让人筋疲力尽了，我希望我能去干……”
but isn't that insane that is insane did your small intestine burst again that was the first time this was before that my large one went as a precursor but wait a minute I wanna know
我希望，你知道的……如果我有更多时间——我们现在确实有时间，而且你热衷于政治——你是因为关心政治才涉足政治的，还是政治让你变得关心政治？我本来就关心政治。所以有没有什么事是你想要做的，也许是朝着那个方向？你一直梦想过这个吗？
do you ever get to the point where because you do work so much and you've done so many amazing things and you're brilliant truly in all of them do you ever get to the point where you're like man this show business thing is exhausting I wish I could do blank
或者别的什么？计划是什么？我没有其他技能，所以我需要继续做这个，否则就会出问题。我需要继续工作。这会让你感到恐慌吗？还是你在挑战自己？
I wish you know if I had more time which we do now and you're very active politically did you do deep because you were political or did deep make you political I was political so is there something you wanna do maybe in that vein have you always dreamed about that
我希望你知道，如果我有更多时间——我们现在确实有——而且你政治上非常活跃，你是因为本来就很关心政治才深入了解的，还是深入了解才让你关心政治的？我本来就很关心政治。所以，在这个方向上你可能有什么想做的事吗？你一直梦想过这个吗？
or anything like what's the plan I don't have any other skills so I need to keep doing this because otherwise it's gonna be a problem I need to keep working does that freak you out or do you challenge yourself
还是别的什么，比如下一步的计划是什么？我没有其他技能，所以我需要继续做这个，否则会有麻烦。我需要继续工作。这会让你感到恐慌吗？还是你在挑战自己？
to think of other things that you enjoy or you know what I mean there are other things I enjoy in life but in terms of like a job you know I need to I need to work as an actor that's what I like to do and really it's the only thing I can really
去想想其他你喜欢的事情，或者你知道我的意思，生活中我还有其他喜欢的事，但就工作而言，你知道，我需要作为一个演员去工作，那是我喜欢做的事，而且真的这也是我唯一真正能
do what about the skills that you've gained while being an actor there in the entertainment business like your knowledge of all the other fields and positions directing producing writing I sort of count all that together
做的事。你在演员生涯和娱乐行业中获得的那些技能呢？比如你对其他领域和职位的了解，导演、制片、编剧，我把这些统统算在一起。
producing is something I definitely enjoy doing and do do and maybe potentially I'll direct at some point but I don't know I'm not sure about that a friend of mine asked me if I had to think of a if I had to choose a job
制片是我确实喜欢做也一直在做的事，也许以后某个时候我也会当导演，但我不知道，我对此不太确定。有个朋友问我，如果非得想一个，如果非得选一份工作，
any other job there were blue collar job I'm like why blue collar just pick it I would be like a landscape artist I would do something with landscaping is that weird did I just lose everybody Gardner would be blue collar
任何其他工作，比如蓝领工作，我说为什么非得是蓝领？随便挑一个吧，我会当个园林景观师，我会做一些和园林相关的事，这很奇怪吗？我是不是把所有人都说懵了？园丁算蓝领吧？
landscape is white collar Gardner I would be a Gardner even mow and blow crew yeah why not I'm gay mow and blow would be easy I think I would work in an airport in what capacity I was a baggage handler when I was a teenager really
景观师算白领，园丁就算蓝领。我愿意当个园丁，哪怕只是开着除草机到处修剪草坪也行，对啊，为什么不呢？我是个同性恋，开着除草机修草坪应该挺轻松的。我觉得我会在机场工作，做什么职位呢？我十几岁的时候当过行李搬运工，真的吗？
was it interesting or not really let me just say this if you're worried that they're going to throw your bags around worry no more because they it was like fragile fragile means extra hard
这工作有意思吗？还是挺无聊的？我这么跟你说吧，如果你担心他们会乱扔你的行李，那就不用担心了，因为他们——这就好比说“易碎”，易碎的意思就是得加倍使劲扔。
Julia what job would you do in the airport would you drive the truck that pushes the plane back no I would drive the go kart that takes the old people to the gate through the terminal with the constant beeping and the light
朱莉娅，你在机场会做什么工作？你会开那种把飞机推出去的卡车吗？不，我会开那种卡丁车，带着老年人穿过航站楼去登机口，车上还有一直哔哔作响的鸣笛和闪烁的灯光。
right excuse me excuse me let me tell you something Will and I cool job Will and I went to Istanbul and when we landed we got that service because we were assholes and in the airport at Istanbul Turkey were like had to be millions
对啊，借过，借过。我跟你说个事，威尔和我——这工作挺酷的。威尔和我去伊斯坦布尔，当我们降落时，我们享受了那种服务，因为我们当时像混蛋一样。伊斯坦布尔土耳其的机场里有足足数百万
of people and we were we were moving through that crowd the asshole Americans at one mile an hour excuse me everybody hated the shit out of us why were you in Istanbul were you there on a vacation
人，而我们就在那片人群中穿行，像一群讨人嫌的美国人，以每小时一英里的速度前进，嘴里喊着“借过”。所有人都对我们恨之入骨。你们为什么去伊斯坦布尔？你们是去度假吗？
yeah we could have walked faster we could have walked faster we did so many of those stupid things in Istanbul remember the huge pepper shaker we came out with this huge pepper shaker that's 19 feet tall Sean's like to the waiter like I have to sorry we need this for a photo
对啊，我们当时其实可以走得更快，我们本可以走得更快的。我们在伊斯坦布尔干了好多那种蠢事，还记得那个巨大的胡椒瓶吗？我们带出了一个巨大的胡椒瓶，有19英尺高。肖恩对服务员说：“对不起，我必须——我们需要这个来拍张照。”
I was like this is my job but anyway so I I'm obsessed with you I have been forever and I wish I was your friend closer I know we are but I wish I was at your house
我当时想：这就是我的工作。不管怎样，总之我——我迷恋你，我一直都这样，我希望我们能成为更亲密的朋友，我知道我们已经是了，但我希望我能去你家
we're not really friends oh you just cut up so I have fond memories about us working together and you being blind on the rest of development that was so much fun Jason that was so much fun
我们其实不是什么朋友。哦，你刚刚把我打断了。所以我对我们一起工作以及你在《发展受阻》里扮演盲人有着美好的回忆，那真的太有趣了，杰森，那真的太有趣了。
Maggie Leiser yeah wasn't I Cherith or Char what was the name I came up it was Cherith right the name of my character was it
玛吉·莱瑟，对啊，我当时不叫谢里丝（Cherith）或者夏尔（Char）吗？我起的名字叫什么来着？是谢里丝对吧？我角色的名字是叫这个吗？
yeah I think I gave you some fake name you were bad at coming up with a name and you said Cherith I'm not like the rest of development aficionado or anything I just remember that but that was so much fun I wanna I'd love to work with you again I wanna at least hang out with you again
对，我想我当时给你起了个假名字。你本来就不擅长起名字，然后你说叫谢里丝。我可不是什么《发展受阻》的死忠粉，我只是刚好记得这件事。但那真的太有趣了，我希望能——我很乐意再次与你合作，我至少想再和你一起出去玩。
so when you come back to Los Angeles don't duck me I'm gonna listen I am on the lookout for this next best thing so if you think of anything good let me know and we'll make it correct I think we are
所以当你回到洛杉矶时，别躲着我。我会听着的，我一直在寻找下一个最棒的机会，所以如果你想到什么好主意，告诉我一声，我们把它促成。我觉得我们正在
hey guess what oh is this it but seriously I'm not fucking around I'm not kidding I really mean that in a wide net like that I think that that's good why not by the way that's the key that right there Jason
嘿，你猜怎么着？哦，就是这个吗？但说真的，我可没开玩笑，我不是在逗你，我是认真的，以这种广撒网的方式，我觉得这挺好的。为什么不呢？顺便说一句，这才是关键，就在那儿，杰森。
you wanted to know how do people get successful cause you're always worried like how do other how do people get successful you ask it's because they put it out there she puts that out there in a very general way not like I need this but just out there I'll send you something that's pretty great and then is that true and then stuff happens it's 100%
你不是一直想知道人们是怎么成功的吗？因为你总是担心“别人是怎么成功的，人们是怎么成功的”，你问吧，那是因为他们把意愿表达了出来。她以一种非常普遍的方式表达了意愿，不是说“我需要这个”，而只是抛出去一句“我会寄给你一些相当棒的东西”，然后——这是真的吗？——然后事情就发生了，100%
true oh good I can't wait to read it do it or pass I don't care I'll keep sending you shit life I believe is 100% what you put out there is it's all vibrational whatever you put out is what you get back 100% of the time that's a lock I totally agree with that it's fun to work with people
是真的。哦太好了，我等不及要读了。做还是不作，我不在乎，我会一直给你发东西。我相信生活100%取决于你向外界投射了什么，一切都是能量共振，你释放出什么，100%就会收获什么，这是铁律。我完全同意这一点。跟喜欢的人一起工作很有趣，
that you like needless to say and who are funny and all three of you guys are maybe one or two of you are funnier than others but I won't I mean just to be I'm working on it though I try but
这是不用多说的，而且他们还很有趣，你们三个人当中——也许你们当中有一两个人比其他人更有趣，但我不会——我是说，为了公平起见，我也在努力，我尽力了，但是
so having said that I really do we've got a podcast we'd love for you to come on but we'd want to put you on the spot do you think about it it feels kind of like a radio show what's the concept it's really nothing we just kind of sit around it's a podcast about nothing and I don't know
话虽如此，我真的很——我们有个播客，很希望你能来做客，但我们可能会当场抛给你一些问题，你考虑一下吧。感觉有点像广播节目，概念是什么？其实没什么概念，我们就是坐在一起瞎聊，这是一个关于虚无的播客，我不知道
if you'd be interested in that but don't answer yet don't answer yet okay I'm thinking about it just FYI I don't really do podcasts so I don't want you to take it personally if I pass no no worries of course no worries at all it's a lot of effort
你对这个有没有兴趣，但先别急着回答，先别答复，好吗？我考虑一下，仅供参考，我其实不上播客节目，所以如果我拒绝了，希望你不要放在心上。不，没事，当然没事，这需要花费很多精力，
but it's been great talking to you anyway yes nice to catch up okay bye honey love you thank you bye Julia that was great great guest Sean I love her I've been such a big fan of hers and you know she was like
但无论如何，能和你聊得很开心。好的，回聊，拜拜，亲爱的，爱你，谢谢，拜拜。朱莉娅，刚才太棒了，真是个绝佳的嘉宾，肖恩。我太喜欢她了，我一直是她的超级粉丝，而且你知道吗，她
21 when she did SNL 21 and pulled out of college to do it and or she quit college I guess I don't know but she pulled herself out she pulled herself out and then God sign fell shortly after that I think it's just and so grounded
上周六夜现场（SNL）时才21岁，21岁，为了这个她从大学退学了，或者说她不念大学了，我不知道，但她退出了，她让自己退出了，然后紧接着上帝的标志（God Sign）就降临了，我觉得这简直——而且她还如此脚踏实地。
I don't know how I know I could have gone much much deeper much more serious with her but I was starting to feel like I want you guys are both friends with her though right you guys hang out I'm not I wish I was I thought you were I wish I was I mean one of your friends
我不知道怎么说——我知道我本来可以跟她聊得更深、更严肃一些，但我开始觉得——你们俩都跟她是朋友，对吧？你们经常一起玩。我不是，我希望我是。我以为你是。我希望我是，我是说，作为你们的朋友之一，
one of your friends oh I see one of the friends and sometimes your jobs a joke you're broke your love life's D.O.A you guys also be there for you when you get older yeah at your friend which reminds me yeah I'm not this is not a bit I mean it is going to seem like a
作为你们的朋友之一，哦我明白了，作为朋友之一。有时候你的工作就是个笑话，你身无分文，你的爱情生活已经彻底玩完。当你们变老的时候，朋友们也会一直在你身边，支持你。是的，在你的朋友身边。这让我想起——是的，我这不是在开玩笑——我是说，这听起来可能像是个
bit but this is totally true yesterday I heard and I said to Alessandro was like I have to say this to Sean because Sean's gonna love because what came on the radio I swear to God was if I could turn back down if I could find
段子，但这是千真万确的。昨天我听到一首歌，我对亚历桑德罗说：“我必须把这个告诉肖恩，因为肖恩一定会喜欢。”因为收音机里放的那首歌，我向上帝发誓，那是《如果时光倒流》（If I Could Turn Back Time），如果我能找到
my way Jesus God till the day I die but fucking I heard it yesterday and I thought of Sean and I knew that we had a show today and I turn back down oh wait Sean
回家的路，天哪，直到我死的那一天。我昨天听到了这首歌，然后我就想到了肖恩，我知道我们今天有个节目，然后——如果时光倒流，哦等等，肖恩，
are you famous for doing share or something like that why'd you think of Sean that's alright you a big fan so get to know your friend we're gonna do an episode we're gonna do one episode it's just the three of us we're just gonna find out what we don't know about each other
你是不是以模仿雪儿（Cher）而出名什么的？你为什么会想到肖恩？好吧，你是她的超级粉丝，那就来深入了解一下你的朋友吧。我们要录制一期节目，只有我们三个人的节目，我们要找出我们对彼此还不够了解的地方。
hang on I'm very embarrassed are you truly known for doing a share yeah one of the most famous episodes of Will and Grace's when Cher came on and I imitated her tell me what Will and Grace is okay so so you'd think it would be like a Will like where there's a Will there's a way and the Grace
等等，我非常尴尬。你真的是以模仿雪儿出名吗？对啊，《威尔和格蕾丝》最著名的剧集之一就是雪儿来客串，而我在里面模仿了她。告诉我《威尔和格蕾丝》讲的是什么？好吧，所以你可能会以为它就像“有志者事竟成”（Where there’s a Will there’s a way）里的那个威尔（Will），然后格蕾丝
of something but it's actually two people is one a preacher one is a gay guy and one is a straight woman and they're perfect for each other although they can't be together well they're perfect for each other was that the idea has this been picked up I swear to God it's just a script it's just a script
代表着某种东西，但实际上是两个人，一个是牧师，一个是同性恋，还有一个是直女，他们是彼此的绝配，尽管他们不能在一起。好吧，他们是彼此的绝配，这就是创意吗？这个剧本被买下来了吗？我向上帝发誓，这只是个剧本，这只是个剧本，
it's not in the bubble I swear to God I never knew it was that they were perfect for each other so wait a minute let's cut all of that they were equally annoying yeah it was like a poles like a negative or north and south or something like
它还没有真正推出。我向上帝发誓，我从来不知道原来他们的核心设定就是天生一对。所以等等，把这些都剪掉吧。他们同样烦人，对，就像两个极点，一个负极，一个正极，或者南极和北极之类的
that and something like that well cut it Sean don't worry Rob dude send me a version where it's not cut um yar okay so wait until next time miss you already guys okay love you guys bye
东西，差不多就是这样。好吧，剪掉它吧，肖恩，别担心。罗伯，老兄，发给我一个没有这些内容的版本。嗯，好的。那就下次见咯，已经开始想念你们了，大家，好的，爱你们，拜拜。
bye can we stop that being our goodbye smart smart smart There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
拜拜。我们能别把这当作告别语吗？精明，精明，精明。本集暂无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。